joining us on the line is misty maris
she's a trial attorney based in new york
city specializing in the defense of
clients and entertainment sports
employment civil rights
and sexual assault and abuse cases and
she is currently appearing and providing
gavel to gavel coverage and analysis of
the derek chauvin trial
for cnn hln misty thanks so much for
joining us i really appreciate it
yeah thank you so much for having me ben
happy to be here yeah so let's talk
about the
the charges in this case the the
prosecution does have a
high burden obviously in any criminal
case you have to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt they're charging
second-degree murder third degree murder
and second-degree manslaughter uh and
those charges
are not as easy to to obtain as as they
sound
so can you walk us through what those
charges mean yeah absolutely so first of
all we have the second-degree murder
charge now that means that the state has
to prove
that chauvin's caused george floyd's
death while committing an intentional
assault
resulting in his unintentional death so
obviously there's a high bar there
to show that chauvin actually committed
the underlying assault which is required
in order to establish that charge so
that's the first and the highest level
charge then we have
third degree unintentional murder now
the standard there is that it's extreme
recklessness to the risk of causing
death now ben
this charge was actually thrown out
prior to the trial
because in general this relates to the
type of case where
you have somebody shooting a gun in a
crowd right it's not a danger to one
specific person
it's a danger to a group of people and
somebody gets killed
as a result of that reckless conduct so
it's a little out of place here in this
trial although now
it's actually being it's part of the
case so it's going to be something the
jury will hear jury charges about and
will ultimately
deliberate on now last we have
second-degree manslaughter this is the
lowest
level of the charges this is when
somebody causes the death of another
by culpable negligence where they create
an unreasonable risk and consciously
take chances of causing death
or great bodily harm so this is more
than a negligence standard it's a
recklessness standard so
that's where the state has to go to
prove
that chauvin is guilty of a crime on any
of those charges and of course as you
said
the standard is beyond a reasonable
doubt a very high bar
for any prosecutor to prove in any case
so frankly as an observer of the trial i
did an entire hour yesterday talking
about how rough the trial had gone for
the prosecution up until yesterday
so yesterday the prosecution seemed to
have a better day prior to that it
seemed like the prosecution was having a
bit of a tough time because the defense
seemed to be making
a fairly compelling case that the the
very least causation ought to be in
doubt as to george floyd's death because
he was saying i can't breathe before he
was on the ground because he had deadly
levels of fentanyl in his system by some
calculations
uh because he had a history of having
overdosed on fentanyl according to his
former girlfriend
and they had also gotten testimony from
prosecution witnesses
about things like the use of force that
suggests that
it's a little bit more complicated than
the prosecution it originally made out
essentially the prosecution had made out
that that chalvin was doing something uh
that was not approved by the minneapolis
police department a lot of those
witnesses
were then called upon to talk about
complicating factors you know crowds
that were threatening
or how or or or alternatives that
theoretically choven could have used
that were actually harsher
than the level of suppression that was
being used or the possibility that that
floyd
could have been like other suspects and
popped awake after falling unconscious
and stuff like that
how did you think the trial is going for
the prosecution
well look ben and i've been covering
this gavel to gavel so i've been
watching it with the jury every single
day so look the first week of the trial
was tough right for the from a defense
perspective and i'm a defense attorney
myself so i tend to look at things
through that scope
you had bystander witnesses you had a
lot of emotional video of course that
video is difficult for anybody to watch
there's there's no if ands or buts about
that
uh and there's not really that much the
defense could do or much traction
they're going to have with these
bystanders
there's not a whole heck of a lot uh
especially when
the court really in in my opinion and
and of course
we defer to the judge he's the one
hearing do making the evidentiary
rulings
allowed for a lot of testimony that i
think in some cases would not have been
relevant and another judge might have
made a different decision
for instance the bystanders were
permitted to testify about
how the watching the incident made them
feel
so as a defense attorney i'd be
objecting dancing all over the room
jumping up and down saying
this really isn't relevant to the case
we also heard from
a bystander who practices mma you know
he
in my view he was a lay witness but he
almost bordered on what would
be considered an expert witness which is
really not appropriate under those
circumstances
that being said defense objects where
they need to object preserves issues for
appeal
and whatnot that's fine now we move into
the second week of the trial where we
heard from the use of force experts
now why do they matter well use of force
is a critical issue in this case if the
use of force that chauvin applied to
george floyd
is reasonable acquittal
right so so the use of force is really a
key component
now who did we see we saw a variety of
officers who do
training on use of force for the
minneapolis police department
we saw chief veronato we saw other
officers who train in other aspects such
as ems critical care and
and whatnot and then it all culminated
with
uh an expert sergeant jody
stinger of lapd who was a paid expert
for the prosecution and ben i gotta tell
you
this week the prosecution fell
apart and i'm talking about the week of
the use of force experts for a few
reasons
so prosecution brings on all of these
witnesses i'm going to focus on chief
renato because i think that
i understand optically as a trial lawyer
myself
the police chief coming out before a
jury and
saying this use of force is unreasonable
sure that has an impact on the jury
right they're thinking oh my gosh this
guy
he's been on the force for x amount of
years you know he's the head of
everything
his opinion matters but i found it to be
interesting because even on direct
examination
the conclusion was this use of force was
absolutely unreasonable there was no
reason to do it blah blah blah
but how did we get there well the answer
to that
question and the rationale to draw that
conclusion was
because it doesn't fit in with the
ethics of of the police department
now to me ben and you're a lawyer as
well
i was expecting a detailed
factual analysis in the testimony of
well our policy says x chauvin did why
look at the video here's where there was
a problem here's where the force was
unreasonable we did not get that and
that was the direct examination
and at that moment i said uh oh this is
not going to go over the prosecution
and then the defense attorney eric
nelson did an excellent job on
cross-examination of calling out
some very very critical testimony
that tends to undercut that conclusion
altogether
what do i mean by that well when we
talked about the policing policies
eric nelson went through a detailed
examination of what those policies say
and what they are
in essence he pointed out the fact that
every single policy has these qualifiers
if reasonable if practicable
if time allows if safe to do so and that
it's not really so easy to say we've got
all these papers that say xyz
the application of those policies in an
actual situation
with somebody that you're trying to
arrest is a whole different ballgame
i thought it was very interesting that
the chief also specifically said
when asked when should chauvin have
released
have released or stood up or released
george floyd he said when he stopped
resisting
oh well now there's testimony that eric
nelson is going to use so you're saying
he's resisting this flies in the face of
a prosecution narrative
that there's this difference between
active and passive resistance
essentially with all of these experts
eric nelson was able to get information
on the record
that says look it is not that simple
just saying that this is unreasonable
well you're not drawing that from a
logical uh
analysis of why it's just a conclusion
without any basis and i think that's
where they really fell apart
this use of force expert
and actually one more comment on aronado
because i think this is a really
important point to make
and something that eric nelson is going
to hammer hammer
home when we ultimately get to closing
arguments where
this is where it will all gel right ben
so all of the information that we're
getting out on cross-examination
is going to be presented in a nice
little package to the jury and it's
going to be the defense narrative
he said to the chief when you're talking
about
unreasonable force you're talking about
an employment decision
you're talking about a decision you made
to terminate
officer chauvin well let's not conflate
that
with whether or not a crime was
committed completely different standards
that's super impactful
so um quick question for you so the the
you know
there were some other use of force
experts who i thought really were not
good for the prosecution johnny mercel
was an mpd user
you're going to say then oh yeah mercer
was terrible i mean he
like so bad that it's almost as though
nelson called him as a defense witness
he specifically said that he had
disbelieved suspects claims of medical
emergency he had suggested that drugs
can make suspects stronger
that suspects can resuscitate after
being unconscious i mean it was just it
was basically exactly what the what the
defense needed in that case but
in fact he said he's had suspects say i
can't breathe
as an excuse right with respect to
getting arrested which was
i thought amazing could that have been
more
on point exactly but the the one
question i wanted to ask you is
yesterday the prosecution brought forth
a couple of medical experts uh and one
of those medical experts in particular
martin tobin
uh he basically testified that he could
tell from the tape
how george floyd died and i i've never
seen anything like that and
to be to be honest with you i mean i
haven't watched tons of criminal trials
but i've never seen anybody claim that
they can watch
a videotape and tell cause of death that
it is not drug induced that is not heart
attack induced that is not anything
induced
simply by looking at frame by frame
respiratory rates
of somebody of somebody dying that
that's
that seems like frankly i'm surprised
that nelson didn't push harder on that
correct ben and and it's interesting
because what nelson did
is he did say you're a pulmonologist
correct you're not a pathologist so
essentially
he he made he got that on the record
that look you're looking at this from
one particular point of view
as a pulmonologist you're not looking at
it as a full picture type of point of
view
uh but i do agree with you and and look
oscar tobin uh
dr tobin was a great witness from a jury
perspective and and that's because he
really
diluted very complicated concepts down
into something that was very
manageable for a jury to consume
applying
as you said this science that i've quite
frankly i've never seen that before and
i go for trials
as a significant portion of my job um
to the to the video and then applying
the medicine
to that point but here's where i think
that this is going to be
a a big problem for the prosecution so
dr
toobin said dr tobin essentially said
there are no other factors that cause
george floyd's death it is
only the fact that chauvin was on his
neck and or back he did
say that he said it didn't really matter
either way neck or back
whatever it still is officer chauvin who
caused his death
on this very precise analysis with
respect to
his lungs and all of that as you said
from watching the video
and making this medical analysis but ben
who's coming down the pike here the
medical examiner
dr baker who lists other specifically in
his report
significant factors such as drug use
such as a heart condition and look as
much as dr
tobin that day was the star of the show
and seemed to be an
excellent witness for the prosecution i
think that's going to be optics
because once the defense is able to
capitalize on the fact that you have a
report
from the medical examiner that lists
these other factors
as being a part of the analysis of what
caused george floyd's death
well now this expert loses a lot of
credibility and i think a lot of us
watching the trial were surprised that
the prosecution's expert was going so
far to say
nothing else contributed to the debt i
don't think anybody expected that we
thought it was going to be
many contributing factors and then the
argument is that officer chauvin's
actions are what's a substantial factor
right um but look i think they're going
to be able to take that apart
quite a bit as more medical experts a
defense is going to present an expert
they don't have to but
they're going well yes they certainly
will of course
but um even just with the medical
examiner dr baker
that's going to be a tough road to hoe
first we know dr baker
after creating the report also
in an interview with police said that if
george floyd
had died in his apartment he would have
called it an overdose yep
so it's not going to jive and that's
where
although yesterday seemed to be a
wonderful day for the prosecution no
doubt
we can't look at it in a vacuum we got
to look at what's to come
and think about what the repercussions
of that are going to be well that's
misty mayor's trial attorney based in
new york city
you can follow her gavel the gathering
devil's gavel coverage of the derek
chauvin trial
for hln really appreciate your time
misty thank you very much ben
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content